ooh I hate that noise that's so gross
[Laughter]
[Music]
today we're going to be painting each
other naked wait what just kidding
drunk even better I think I've known
Clark as long as I've been working here
two years and now I suck at painting I
am NOT a Picasso I need to alcohol I
think so I think it's time those are
some cute as my glasses please cheers
Cheers let's get started [ __ ] cha cha
ok pay pay pay [ __ ] paint paint paint
like this cameras look prettier blink
Brenda would you let me cut your ear off
you know depends on the amount of money
you offer you look like Mozart or Bach
or baked or something I'm so sorry it's
okay oh I am not offended it would be
cute
what is if we took out a kilo three two
one go that's what best friend do drink
together for the portraits Oh your nose
just took an epic turn I kind of Ivan
this it's like forget what people no
exception is of you Brenda turn to me
Brenda turn to me don't let society say
what you look and feel like come on
Fenian ami she's not a [ __ ] weird
life is spontaneous bro life is just
flicking paint and just doing whatever
it feels and emotions exactly whatever
I'm like not like thrilled with it you
look a little bit like an alien am I
covered in paint
yeah man you guys so many splashes in
your face Brenda I have something I want
to show you oh god okay oh I haven't
looked at Clarke's I'm excited to see
what it is
should we try anything oh my god
first of all that's [ __ ] cute I love
that man dude this is awesome
you've definitely taken some artistic
liberties it's kind of fun to put your
thoughts down about your friend in a
different way
oh you're great you're funny you're kind
but like show that [ __ ] through a
painting bro doing something for Vaughan
was pretty special to dedicate the time
to everything that makes him so awesome
and cool Jen just pour wine on this I
think so oh my god crying wine that's
cool that's really cool drunk friends
out
[Music]
you
[Music]